in this short video we'll talk about the
centromeres centromeres are one type of
structure present in a eukaryotic
metaphysic chromosome centromere is the
constricted region of mitotic
chromosomes that connects the sister
chromatic together the centromere links
the sister chromatic during the time of
cell division and the centromere also
demarcates the chromosome into two
different arms the short arm which is
also known as P arm and the long arm
which is known as Q arms but what is so
special about the centromere before
starting let me tell you centromeric
kind of organization can be seen in the
metaphysic chromosome in other stages of
the cell division
the centromeric organization is not
highly visible
now let me talk about the classification
of centromeres depending on the position
of centromere they can be classified
into several categories like metacentric
where the centromere is along the middle
portion of the chromosome
metacentric where the centromere is
positioned a little bit below or above
the Middle Point
there could be acrocentric where the
centromere is situated towards one end
of the chromosome that means one arm is
much bigger than the other one
and the last one is telocentric
chromosome which is generally not found
in eukaryotes in this case the
centromere is located at one end of the
chromosome
based on sequence specificity
centromeres can be divided into two
groups Regional centromeres and the
point centromeres Regional centromeres
are very common in eukaryotes in
Regional centromeres the DNA sequence
which are associated in the centromeres
contribute to the function but they do
not Define the function of the
centromere
but in case of Point centromeres the DNA
sequence is pretty much necessary and
sufficient to specify the centromeric
function
Point centromeres are very much common
in budding yeast whereas the
Regional centromeres are common in other
eukaryotic cells like mammalian cells
now the point centromere is generally
appear to be
150 base pairs in the buddingist whereas
the regional centromeres range several a
hundred KBs
in eukaryotic cells
so there are a lot of differences
between them
now let's talk about the molecular
composition of a centromere
so before centromere we should
understand the building block of
chromosome is actually nucleosome which
is a combination of histone octumer and
the DNA wrapped around it so this is a
basic subunit of actually chromosome
now what is so special about the
chromatin which is present in the
centromere first of all this particular
centromedic chromatin is
heterochromatinized
and centromere
plays key role in the division
now the chromatin in the centromere is
extremely compact they have specific
kind of modifications in the nucleosome
which we would be talking about
so first of all these modifications
Define the centromeric region
and also there are unique histone
variants present in the nucleosome in
the centromeric region
especially synth a which is the H3
variant is present or abundant in the
centromeric region
also centromere contains repetitive DNA
sequences called Alpha satellites so
these three are peculiar of molecular
features of the centromeric region
now there are several kind of
modification that is happening in the
centromeric region in the nucleosome one
such modification is histone H3
phosphorylation with the help of Aurora
B kinase
and this modification happens in the
h3s10 residue which attracts protein
like
hst2p which actually can cleave off
certain acetyl group from the H4 histone
and this deacetylation leads to further
compaction of the chromatin in the
centromeric region and this is one of
the way by which heterochromatinization
can be achieved in the centromeric
region
now centromere is super important
because when the chromosomes are
segregating during the cell division
centromeres ensures that this
segregation happens in a proper fashion
and the way it does that by by
interacting with the kinetoco region
which is a protein-rich region around
the centromedic portion now if proper
segregation doesn't happen then there
could be detrimental anomalies
so the kinetochore is a protein-rich
segment around the centromere which
ensures proper microtubule binding and
tension sensing in this particular
region when the tension is proper only
then cell divides to pull it away
so there are three portions of the
kinetic core the inner kinetoccur outer
kineticore and the five breast layer
fibrous layer guides the microtubule
towards this kinetochord region and
allows the docking of microtubule in
this region so all these structures help
in tension sensing there are many
proteins and kinases associated with
this region which ensures that proper
tension is sensed before the chromosome
can segregate in a later video we'll
talk more about the kinetochore and its
role in the metaphysics in the
anaphysics separation
for now that's pretty much it if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
you can get more notes and flash cards
in my Facebook channel uh you can also
find notes in Instagram links are in the
description you can support the Channel
with super thanks you can pay via paytm
UPI PayPal Etc see you in next video